imagine hearing this in church
well in finland you can heavy metal is
very popular in finland i think we are
the world leader of that
in fact finland has the most heavy metal
bands per capita in the world
it's so popular it's showing up in
places you wouldn't expect
[Music]
the metal mass mastermind my name is
haka kekalai and i'm a pastor in
lutheran church
i've been a metal fan since 1970
and when i became
a pastor it was my dream to do metal and
masses heavy metal might seem completely
out of place at church
but the surfaces aren't as different as
you might think
metal mass is quite normal mass but we
have arranged all humans in metal music
this whom sounds safe in our official
hymnbook
we have two guitarists and bass player
and also keyboards and drums and i am a
master of the whole ceremony
[Music]
you might think the intense music would
turn church-goers off
but it's had just the opposite effect
metal masses are quite popular now in
finland churches are quite full every
kind of people comes to battle masses
people have more fun in our masses
for me metal music is very positive and
relaxing music it's nothing to do with
saturn or satanism we are doing because
of god for god
after every mass
i meet people outside they say that they
are so full of joy and fun god loves
mental music
and god loves us
[Music]